justement les joindre et sur une
terrasse du centre-ville de montréal
place des festivals
là où l'action se passe julie lacroix et
adib alkhalidey messieurs bonjour ça va
oui savoir parce que je me compte
chanceux en plein festival avoir accès à
vous à neuf jours de votre soirée donc
vous avez carte blanche n'est ce pas
comment vous vous sentez fébrile
moi j'ai juste très près je le vois je
suis comme si une carte blanche ça va
être avec des amis c'est des sketches
qu'on peut ou des stand-up qu'on peut
juste faire dans un genre de gala comme
ça que j'ai juste très très hot money
convainc pas confiant mais on commence à
apprécier ce qu'on te préparer pour le
gala le faisait tous cas là juste pour
rire quand même carte blanche le nom le
dit et comme une notion de liberté dans
tout ça à ce stade ci est ce que ce
genre de chose à laquelle vous espériez
absolument je pense que un gala juste
pour rire animé un gala déjà enfin reims
ça a toujours été un rêve en tout cas
pour moi quand j'étais plus jeune je
suis rendu je pense 8,9 lui son premier
pays il anime c'est le recul c'est la
recrue avec dans une position encore
plus particulière là que quelqu'un qui
est à sa première fois parce qu ils lui
volent animé mais mais je pense à animer
un gala c'est le rêve de n'importe quel
humoriste dans le sens que quand on est
petit on apprend à rêver à ce métier là
en regardant la télé en entendant la
tourner en voyant les artistes passés
après l'autre est un peu comme tout
comme new york tout à fait relatif c'est
comme même si tu l'as vu tu l'as vu tout
à vie à la télé quand tu arrives de
dante faire waouh jean-yves lui seul
registre exactes sur 100% des sensations
qui en fait existe depuis super
longtemps dans tes rêves les plus fous
vous êtes dans votre rêve le plus fou
aurait eu cent ans on doit assumer mais
oui parce que tu en veux pas me servir
moi j'aide à discuter à dire c'est un de
mes plus grands rêves mais quand j'y
repense quand j'étais petit c'était
vraiment un des plus grands vins c'est
le cas après ouais c'est vrai que j'ai
appris tout ce que j'avais sur le
monstre en regardant les dvd à venir
dans les émissions canal d en garder
juste la chanson je me vois déjà qu'on
va rentrer sur scène avec la chanson
qu'on connaît tous
de badouri je suis un québécois
d'origine arabe ça de corse un gala sur
moi j'ai j'ai décidé que j'allais faire
de l'humour quand j'ai vu le dvd des
mers maman de 2005 quand j'ai vu rachid
badouri c'était mon premier argument
pour aller voir mes parents puis dire
regardez c'est possible pour les arabes
aussi à damas
en tout cas ça va donner quand même mon
petit boost qui me fallait qu'est ce qui
se passe à ce moment on a l'impression
que les choses changent que des
mouvements de plaques tectoniques
nouvelle génération nouveau discours
c'est plus diversifiée mais je pensais
des cycles animaux je pense que
justement fait partie d'un nouveau cycle
souvent quand j'étais en tournée on dit
que les dés les propriétaires de salles
disent on a jamais vu ces gens là dans
nos salles parce que c'est plus jeunes
soit les gens gagnaient 1 ça c'est des
gens plus vieux je pense que justement
est ce que c'est juste la jeunesse ben
en fait
avant il y avait comme une heure comme
moi je suis arrivé il ya neuf ans il y
avait une obsession de la vedette c'est
vrai moi là je pourrai gagner 2 3 fois
plus d'argent en allant travailler dans
le privé mais je suis debout travailler
à la télé il fallait comme légal est
devenue une affaire il faut de la v
département de juste pour rire juste
pour rire mais l'industrie en général il
y avait juste une obsession c'est comme
si on ne portait pas attention vraiment
potentiel des gens mais juste qu'un kit
établi puis qu'il veut d'être sacré
comme un clivage a créé comme notre
génération à nous qui a décidé de banque
a décidé de travailler ensemble parce
que on se sent pas
oui on se sentait pas nécessairement
accueillis par par par l'ordre établi
affecté ça crée des liens tellement fort
justement par exemple julien et moi puis
vous allez retrouver avec d'autres
artistes de notre génération et je
t'offre les premiers billets faut jamais
avec une ethnie parce que je savais que
cela donnera
méditez pas dispo agency pas julien
qu'on en voit d'habitude pour faire
bonne première impression
ça crée des liens tellement fort que
rendu là aujourd'hui avec l'expérience
qu'on a on se retrouve dans le ces
situations là où les gens pensent qu'on
on s'est associés parce que ça va être
drôle julien perdu ben non c'est parce
qu on aime travailler ensemble depuis
des années que ça a commencé en deux
grandes piles à ça je pense que ça
atteint un peu le juste prix pour que
les gens saisissent bien ce qui se passe
à ce moment vraiment sur le terrain
concrètement il ya des comedy club
l'humour ça se passe dans un univers
complètement éclaté au québec par
rapport à il ya dix quinze ans 1 qu'est
ce qui vous frappe là dedans
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui doit être
dire que moi je trouve fabuleux c'est de
voir autant les vieux de la vieille qui
est des nouveaux humoristes se
précipiter dans les comédies club pour
roder leur gala je pensais déjà établi
qu'ils avaient jamais regarder tant que
ça un gala comme ça j'ai jamais là on
est des chemins et des comedy club à
montréal en un peu partout qu'on voit
les gens courir d'une soirée à l'autre
voire le meilleur matériel possible je
demande c'est je pense pas que le
meilleur gagne mes cheveux que c'est
justement le meilleur produit c'est ce
que tu veux offrir une ombre justement
une vedette avec son sabot que tout le
monde c'est tout le monde est dans le
même sens adam qui va offrir la qualité
puis d'en poursuivre en mathématiques
des rêves les plus fous en terminant
quand vous voyez l'humour j'ai pas dans
dix quinze ans en espérant vous soyez
toujours dans le portrait ckoi l'idéal
finalement atteint moi en tout cas je
pense que c'est de plus en plus dur de
nos jours d'avoir des projets de société
et que je pense il faudrait que ramener
ça quelque chose de plus simple et plus
petit musée avoir des projets de société
culturelle moi j'aimerais beaucoup qu'au
québec on assume que c'est la capitale
internationale du stand up en français
c'est ça notre force
il ya tellement de gens qui sont
passionnés par ce que si les gens
embarquaient et qui venait dans les
comédies curable c'est pas juste les
gros événements comme les galas juste
pour rire dans les bars 10e
marty déjà entre amis qui vit de tous
les âges la posture en ce moment c'est
quasiment que des gemmes
mais c'est quoi nourrir et beaucoup à
montréal mais de partout je pense
qu'avec des phénomènes comme le bordel
et tout ça c'est le terminal
c'est l'fun de voir que les québécois se
disent ça c'est notre force
culturellement ici on est passionné par
sa le mot de la fin revient
malheureusement notre gala est complet
mais on a libéré 30 billets que ça c'est
intéressant quand même on avait 30
billets pour nos amis famille mais on a
décidé de produire
ils ont bataillé des prêts on et on les
remet en vente parce qu'ils nous ont pas
encourager au début de soirée non mais
c'est vrai qu'on les libère on libère
les 30 billets qui étaient qui était
destiné aux familles amis parce que
parce que la demande est élevée plus on
trouve ça l'fun
on trouvait ça drôle de dire on ne
touche pas mon choix
quelque chose qu'à cgt je pense avoir
fait dire ça très bien et solide a quand
même je suis pas assez bon
et merci beaucoup des comme ça
amusez-vous ses cinq partenaires semaine
prochaine ciao